is the gtx 1180 just a rebranded gtx
980ti
for $1,500
[Music]
welcome to horace hobbies the gtx 1180
has been rumored for quite a while now
and there has been a variety of release
states prices and specs from a release
this month to release not till 2019 from
a gaming monster to just a rebranded
1080 TI and from $700 all the way to
$1500 so which of these predictions is
true and what should you expect so
starting off with the price because if
the price is outrageously high then it
doesn't really matter what the release
date or specs really are so it's the gtx
actually going to cost $1500 like an
asus strix 1180 leaked suggested well
first of all that for sale lead is
really easy to fake and I don't believe
that it is true and there is really in
no way that NVIDIA is going to price the
GTX an 1180 at $1500 it just makes no
sense for a mainstream GPU that's
literally over double the price after
last flagship also in video already has
high level GPUs in that range for those
types of users so it really makes no
sense for them to put a gaming GPU up
there as well as a result I am very
confident that the gtx 1180 will not
cost $1500 in fact it most likely won't
even cost $1000 thus the maximum
reasonable cost the gtx at 1180 is going
to come in at is going to be $1000 but
what is a lot more likely is something
in the 700s like what gamer mel
suggested with this leak at seven
hundred and twenty dollars and that was
for a third party variant card so the
founders edition card will most likely
come in at $700 just like its
predecessors if anything it may go a
little higher into 700s like 750 dollars
but it most likely won't go into the
800s at least not for the founders
Edition card and a price over $1000 is
really quite unlikely it doesn't matter
what type of performance it has because
it just doesn't make sense to place a
mainstream platform
at such a higher price so as a result
the price is not going to be
outrageously high like some rumors
suggest it may increase a little over
last generation price but realistically
it's not going to over double so next
what about the performance this the
tensor is just going to be a rebranded
11 series well the answer is no first of
all GE ddr six memory production has
already started and I doubt SK Hynix
is starting production right now so that
Envia can use G DDR six memory in there
are 12 series cards two years later thus
the eleventh series is going to have GD
or six memory and plus the eleventh
series is not a rebrand because a simple
rebrand wouldn't have such a big upgrade
also it has been over two years since
the tenth series cards released and so
it doesn't make sense to rebrand them so
late and try to keep it going forward I
know that Nvidia wants to give away as
less performance as possible but Nvidia
also wants to make as much money as
possible and for Nvidia to maximize
sales they have to provide a solid
upgrade over the tenth series in order
to do that because then the eleventh
series will not only attract new
builders but also builders who are
wanting to upgrade from their 10 series
GPUs
and this would dramatically increase
sales and profit and considering their
sales are already 20% down
I really doubt they want that downfall
to keep going
overall the eleventh series will not be
a rebrand of the 10 series because it
has been so long since the 10 series
came out and NVIDIA wants to entice as
many people as they can
to buy the new 11 Series cards and to do
that they need to provide a good solid
upgrade over the 10 series finally when
is the gtx 1180 going to come out is it
not coming out all the way till 2019
well NVIDIA is plenty to detail their
new 1100 series cards at the hot chips
conference in August and it just doesn't
make sense for them to wait over four
months after this conference to actually
release the cards as a result a much
more likely timeframe for the release of
these new cards is at the end of August
or September and it would start out with
the gtx 1180
and we would see a staggered release
after that also I really doubt Nvidia
would want to miss out on all the
holiday sales by waiting all the way
till 2019 so considering all this don't
buy a 10 Series card right now because
it doesn't really make sense to buy an
almost outdated card if you were looking
for more value then you should
definitely wait for the 1100 series and
buy the 11 or Sears equivalent biggest
it will most likely come in at around
the same price but provide you with a
lot more performance if you are looking
to save some more money or you are
already satisfied with the performance
that you would get with the 10 series
then you should still wait for the 1100
series cards and then buy the 10 series
cards because the 10 series cars will
indeed go down in price after you 1100
series cards come out but that's just
why I think what do you guys think how
much performance do you think the gtx
1180 will have and do you think that it
is worth it make sure to comment down
below what you guys think because I do
read all my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like to
really make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing if you guys like to
see more
videos just like this one but until next
time bye
[Music]